hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut mir auch
danke irgendwie regt mich diese kamera
manchmal auf so scharf stellen auf mich
nicht auch den hintergrund
ich weiß nicht das fällt wahrscheinlich
gar nicht mal so stark auf aber diese
kamera fokussiert nicht nichts jetzt
haben wir leute wir haben gerade
mittwoch den elften oder zwölften
september ich glaube der elfte september
es heute genau und der eine oder andere
als bestimmt schon mitbekommen meine
freundin und ich wir machen bei der
neuen stadt film von grass klassenfahrt
mit der einzigen youtube serie von jonas
und dem anderen jonas genau und ich
werde auch schon in einer halben stunde
abgeholt und dann fliegen wir erst nach
münchen und von münchen nach warschau in
polen warum auch immer wieder dass in
polen drin
ich war noch nie in polen deswegen ich
bin gespannt und ich habe richtig lust
ich freue mich auch auf die ganzen leute
die mit spielen einige von denen kenne
ich schon
die anderen noch nicht also den
hamburger so ein paar weitere youtuber
die da mitmachen also ich bin ja
youtuber oder sagen wir mal influenza
von just schaden auf bestimmten cooler
typ kekse tv jonas jan o der macht musik
kann wahrscheinlich auch einige von euch
den kann ich aber auch schon und ich
weiß nicht ob ich habe jetzt keinen
vergessen die anderen lehrer nicht alle
kennen ich freue mich sehr und wir sehen
uns dann gleich am flughafen oder war
noch immer ihr handgepäck koffer reicht
absolut für mich für eine woche also wir
sind da wirklich fast eine woche bisher
noch auf gesund eine banane mitnehmen
das hier sind die sachen die ich nicht
brauche wir sollten uns jeder so ein
paar outfit zusammenstellen für den
charakter den gespielen ich spiele einen
charakter obwohl am besten verhält sich
gar nicht soviel dass er ja auch nicht
also ich habe richtig bock eine woche
sozusagen klassenfahrt wie lang nicht
mehr auf klassenfahrt schon länger ich
freue mich und ja viel spaß mit dem blog
ich habe keine ahnung wie viele blogs
ist geben dir davon aber wir werden
sehen so leute wir sind uns mittlerweile
schon angekommen hier in münchen dass
der tory hallodri winkmann
hallo und machen uns jetzt auf den weg
hier zum anschluss geld fehle jetzt mal
hier genau das was ich sehe weil ich
selber zu film finde ich finde ich total
unangenehm in solchen situationen
deswegen und tobi vegetiert freut sich
schon dass leute mich wir sehen uns dann
gleich mal vielleicht im flieger sitzen
oder auch nicht wir sind immer noch in
münchen einmal schafschur mittel ich
habe immer probleme mit der kamera jetzt
geht es weiter hier zum flugzeug ab nach
warschau ich habe gut machst du das
das doch eigentlich mal so das beste
wenn man durch seinen gang zum flugzeug
laufen kann weil uns musste raus muss
nächste woche also ich bin übrigens der
einzige hier der mit handgepäck aus
kommt ja auch erst mal kommen
das ist doch auch handgepäck
nein
was besser nicht so groß da hatte ich
aber wer ordentlich verpackt diese
kamera so abgestellt einfach nicht
schlafen kannst du das mal übernehmen
was mache ich denn hier falsch so leute
man muss leider sagen ein kleines
problem ist aufgetreten
und zwar sind alle unsere koffer da
außer der von berliner die mit einem
blonden haaren
ihr koffer ist weg und jetzt habe ich
ein problem weil wenn ihr körper nicht
da ist können wir auch nicht mal das
macht man ja nicht deswegen warten wir
jetzt auf ihren koffer weil sonst gibt
keinen krach machen könnt ihr meine
unterhose gar nicht allein okay leute
mittlerweile schon in warschau gelandet
ich glaube ich habe mich aber eben schon
gemeldet und jetzt gerade hier eine
freundlicherweise abholt beim auto und
sind jetzt aber wir sind schon da ne
sind jetzt da also hier also ich würde
auch sagen das sieht komisch aus dass
schnell blog raum auf jeden fall muss
man sagen wir sind hier mitten im
nirgendwo und es werde licht grün cool
so leute herzlich willkommen einen
wunderschönen guten morgen hier aus
warschau wir sind gestern schon hier
angekommen und ich hab leider gestern
zwölf filmen wir waren auch alle sehr
müde und haben nicht nur noch so ein
bisschen gehabt sondern auch schlafen
gegangen also man muss sagen das sieht
hier auf jeden fall alles super
entspannt aus hier ist eine sitzecke da
kann man dann auch immer frühstücken ich
darf man auch filme oder ich muss mir
jetzt fertig machen ich weiß ja auch
schon gesagt habe ich habe sowas ja noch
nie mitgespielt also bei sonderserie
deswegen ich will dich anstrengen das
ist googles wir gehen das sofort nach
draußen
wir haben hier auf jeden fall so ein
bootcamp also das gelände ist riesig so
und hier geht man dann raus ich glaube
ich den haben wir gerade schon wunderbar
gefrühstückt hallo in die runde
hallo hallo hier könnte man ein ganzes
fußballspiel austragen so groß ist dass
man das beste sind natürlich immer
pavillon so leicht ist jetzt auch schon
los das problem ist ich bin der einzige
der sondern seinen körper noch nicht
unten hat heute brauchen jetzt alle
unsere koffer das ist unser zimmer
ich muss noch schnell die haare machen
und dann drehen wir die erste szene ich
bin sehr gespannt ich hoffe ich
kann das überhaupt lässt sie kann man
jetzt mal hier sehen wir uns gleich
leute herzlich willkommen zurück man
muss sagen dieses haus hier ist so
riesig die gibt es locker 30
verschiedene bäder also ohne spaß das
hier ist jetzt halt wieder ein anderes
das ist nicht unser es weiter jetzt
zeige ich euch mal ganz schön unser
zimmer eigentlich super entspannt haben
wir heute unser bett ist absolut nicht
fertig gemacht hier die sachen alles
bisschen aufgeräumt das hier ist unser
bad super leiste dusche und hier hat man
auch einen geilen ausblick fenster
wurden geputzt aber ist doch so schlimm
kann hier halt alles super sehen auf
jeden fall werde ich schon in meinem
zweiten autos heute morgen haben wir in
anderen outfits gedreht da draußen
drehen so gerade die leute also drehen
die irgendwie so eine bestimmte szene
ich kann gerade aussetzen und so sieht
das dann halt irgendwie ungefähr immer
aus also ich mache was ich auch zum
ersten mal hallo und ist immer wieder
rein und hier hinter mir ist dann so
eine was wir da auf jeden fall ist die
sonne chillout ecke und die gucken rät
auch irgendwie seinen film dann haben
wir da hallo das ist das marie dass
annika und sony hallo und hier ist dann
die eingangstür von diesem ganzen
gebäude also wie gesagt ein mega fährt
ist anwesend wir sind auf 17 leute ich
habe öfter mal die frage gestellt
bekommen was ich ihr dann eigentlich für
eine rolle spiele also ich glaube ich
hab's mal so ein bisschen erzählt ich
spiele ja mit marie so ein pärchen und
ich bin so ein typ ich bin so ein
bisschen ja wie soll ich sagen so ein
bisschen durch den wind weil ich hin und
wieder drogen konsumiere also das ist
meine rolle
deswegen habe ich auch so eine mütze auf
und so eine jogginghose an und so also
bisher noch ein auf dieses vielleicht
ist das jetzt ein bisschen zu stereotyp
ish aber eigentlich also ich glaub mein
outfit heute passt ganz gut und hinter
mir könnt ihr jetzt einmal das ganze
haus sehen also heute ist der erste
drehtag ich versuche euch gleich noch
mal so ein bisschen die ganzen leute
einmal vorzustellen die hier mitspielen
super neuestes haus normalerweise finden
hier so bootcamps stadt bootcamp
akademie leute mittlerweile habe ich
schon das dritte auto wird heute an
ich habe mich schon dreimal umgezogen
und
wir müssen mal ganz kurz bei dir
anfangen
sag mir deinen namen und welche rolle
des spiels holzerath hast du noch mal
von vorne alles klar es freut mich und
du du bist marie und jetzt eine ehrliche
und du da oben in der eu liegt und
welche rolle spielst du spielen sowie
klassische kamera ist ich habe einfach
nur deine nase drauf ok und du musst
auch einmal kurz seinen namen sagen und
wie die den charakter ist okay dann hat
und jetzt nochmal das freut mich nicht
eine dusche und hier haben wir ja du
musst einmal sagen wie deine rolle als
spirituell und ich habe was in meiner
stieß danach ja wissen sorry das ist
sowie den kennt ja schon der macht die
kamera und das ist jonas du musst auch
einmal kurz sagen wieder einen charakter
ist ein charakteristikum ok und du bist
bisschen zurückgeblieben als gar
ja beides halt so das ist felix der
macht die aufnahmeleitung und das ist
der andere jonas du musst auch aber ganz
so eine rolle erklären
also ich bin unterricht wie 36 am set
das ist am anfang ein bisschen uncool
das machen aber im grunde des
entspannten glauben ich weiß es ist
spannend wie zeigt dass man sich halt
dann auch so also hört sich richtig
interessant
ich komme ja wir haben jetzt auf jeden
fall schon den zweiten tag
und hier gibt es schon immer so ein
caterer der bringt morgens mittags und
abends essen und da draußen essen jetzt
alle also wir haben auf jeden fall
wetter ja und ich sitze davon in der
ecke heute gibt es so reibekuchen falls
man das so sagt bei euch keine ahnung
ich glaube ich von region zu region
unterschiedlich was das hier ist weiß
ich nicht sid nicht so appetitlich aus
und dann noch so ein bisschen salat
alles essen ist eigentlich voll in
ordnung ich bin jetzt gerade hier so ein
foto machen dass wir alle drauf sind
aber das ist schwieriger als man denkt
weil wir sind nicht mal die hälfte
wir müssen noch kurz weitere charaktere
vorstellen die auch noch nicht in meinem
video sind und zweimal haben wir hier zu
meiner rechten du musst einmal einen
vornamen seinen willen haben sagen und
dann den namen in der serie spielt und
das ok sehr gut und das ist unsere
klassenlehrerin das ist frau stelle ich
mal kurz vor cook einfach so hier oben
hin
ja klar wo sonst
cook sony kameras aber kannst auch mich
angucken wenn du mich lieber an clubs
als die kamera stehe ich alles gut also
ich bin jenny und ich spiele bei claas
klassenfahrt dies auch fleisch also hat
sich auf jeden fall jung gehalten finde
ich muss sagen ich glaube ich habe jetzt
fast alle drin
wir gehen noch einmal nach oben man kann
sogar sagen wie du heißen welche rolle
gespielt
also nicht anders im haus ist jetzt
absolute ruhe
deswegen wollte ich sagen dass wir mit
diesem kleinen block ich hoffe er hat
welche gefallen
es wird sicherlich noch einige geben ich
weiß nicht wir sind ja noch fünf jahre
oder so ne also das war es aber die den
kanal
wann fängt das an am ersten oktober
kommt die erste folge kommt die erste
folge auf dem gras klassenfahrt kanal
und ja wir sehen uns ins warum heißt die
alex frei